just it's graves is French for high
production quality
sorry GU so it's just trying to turn
this into Skrillex it is to say here on
its grace and it's time for me to talk
back to you let's start on Twitter mic
mgtv new person new person new person am
i sticking with that some of you
suggested saying new graces new graces
new graces I think I'm just gonna stick
with person cuz they're all people and I
don't like calling you graces because it
makes us feel like we're some cult now
that I hate calling me that this is
taking up too much time of the video
probably don't know when a new person
comments on one of my videos I praise
them I welcome them to the it's grace
family mic mgtv you that sounds like the
male version of HGTV my mgtv man guys TV
hey you gay gay gay gay gay
hey you're gay you're a true bug just
pre-ordered get the code online you are
nailing it
I just high-fived your boner my life as
Beth new person new person new person my
life is Beth more like my life as Beth
would be so great except my life is as
Macbeth and I killed the things and the
skull in my hand culture if you're just
tuning in now I swear I don't have a
learning disability watch a gray
something increases my sense of humor
and ability to make jokes that are
actually funny thanks grace side effects
may include penis enlargement irritable
bowel constant questioning of is this
worth it slash right and slowness and
constants learnis of speech even when
sober now let's go to YouTube
that's a website where it can be good to
person to person new person weird can be
good too more like yeah that also
spelling out full words can be good too
to each their own
oh WN not affiliate with Oprah Winfrey
but oh
you want chat your the rating system
should be goose faces or goose foots or
goose butts or loosey goosey czar just
goose ease
just look at my pro pic yeah your
profile pic is goose and I am
apprehensive of using goose faces as a
judgment system because I've exploited
that animal enough and she doesn't need
that I mean the jowls on her make for a
great still image but she I'll figure
out something
bong la new person new person to person
song la more like don't drop that thun
to dance your brother she sounds like
she is high does high have a sound is it
like we're like oh like like like like
like wart or like oops
like oops let me know in the comments
below
Breanna eats a new person to person to
person brandy Easton more like Breanna
is easy son
he's will have sex with your son and
that's okay cuz he needs it you've a
brother this was genius well
Kanye's a genius I'm just here now let's
go to tumblr that's right I'm gonna
start including your Tumblr comments u2t
once that's supposed to be positive
snacks and Bailey's new person to person
to person snacks and Bailey it's more
like that's a great party you've accrued
look what came today yes camp Takota
calm I sold this on my tumblr tag and I
actually for a very brief moment [ __ ] it
this was Hannah Hart wearing a wig but
you are a very lovely human and you have
leopard print on your wall how did you
do that why'd you do that you're going
through a phase but I'm glad you like
camp Takota sure it looks great on you
doodle fruit new person to person to
person doodle fruit more like this
doodle fruit yeah uh perfect beauty
queen Ted of awesome anyone I'm assuming
that this is rose rosey Hannah mamrie
and I and we all have very sinister
looks on earth it's one of us just took
a huge in someone's bathroom and we're
trying to keep it a secret it's not you
it's great new person new person new
person it's not you it's grace more like
yeah this is always me beautiful bride
Grace has been the sweetest peach lately
I'm not sure how to handle it I'm sorry
sometimes I feel an emotion called happy
and I expressed it to you guys I have a
lactose issue and I realized that a
muscle sincerity and sensitive so that's
always fun sit fern talking back to you
guys I hope that you have a wonderful
day I don't know simply Sam 23 new
person new person new person simply Sam
23 more like 23 was Michael Jordan's
number that's one of the only athletic
statistics facts I know so you must be
great at mad ups also Space Jam remember
Michael Jordan was in that crossover
actor so always double dribble you know
this is praising or it's just a
smorgasbord of non-sensory loving the
new channel very happy you're so close
to 1 million again also new person what
about new graces alerts I don't know I
just I think new person is gonna I just
cuz you're a person and you're new here
so you're a new new person and also
maybe if you're ever like questioning
that you're stuck in a rut this saying
that you're a new person might like
inspire you to be like I am a new purse
and I'm gonna go out there and get it
and by it I mean that sweet sweet puss